[Applause]
i want to talk about snl a little bit
because have you have you guys noticed a
lot of comics
[ __ ] all over snl on twitter yeah uh
this has been going on for a while yeah
uh
i admittedly do not watch snl i honestly
forget it's on
it could be saturday night and you'll
say what's on tv and i'll be like son i
don't know yeah
especially with playoffs there's like
fights going on there's a lot of other
[ __ ] going on
to be fair chris rock was on this
weekend it's a good show to watch with
your family
it's like hey what do we watch it's like
that's an easy go-to you got parents
that understand the references
i do not ah okay so that is interesting
you can watch with the whole family you
don't have to worry about it being too
offensive
that's crazy though because when we were
kids it was on at
midnight or whatever specifically
because they said crazy [ __ ] hmm
so you're saying it changed yeah okay
um so basically what happened is i'm
seeing a lot of activity on twitter of
comics just [ __ ] on snl this has
been like the last
i would say a few years yeah but it's
getting more and more popular
and i'm concerned snl is going through
like a dane cook phase where
it's becoming cool to dislike like dane
cook was the biggest thing in the entire
world
i did madison square garden and then
he kind of like jumped the shark if you
will
you remember that yeah he got too big he
got like too big or something like that
and and louis accused him of stealing a
joke and isn't it funny
that louie made an accusation that
doesn't really seem true
and ruin somebody's career oh and now
he's in doing and doing an entire
special
about how [ __ ] up it is that people
can just make accusations and everybody
believes it
and they elevate their profile as
accusers and the accused can't defend
himself at all oh my god
i just put that together at this moment
but that should make a lot of sense good
that was really good that you did that
are you doing it sometimes like father
ben right there right yeah
listen up father that's how it's done
son how's it glass louis ck yeah i mean
don't throw stones
or jerk off on the windows that's louis
so much harder to jerk off in your house
with glass though yeah
yeah everybody's just looking at you nah
he wants that glass house though
i built his house of all windows florida
ceilings
yo free louis c.k man
what do you mean like i don't know just
free him his album's free now is that
actually
just giving that [ __ ] away free louie
man
he gave me a compliment once yeah i
didn't see him laughing at you
i got complimented post allegation
pre-allegation louis ain't touching you
son yeah he might not touch me
post he gotta be humbled a little bit
paul is he gonna force you to listen his
compliments and you're gonna get these
compliments
it's all i can force you to do now
the door of the green room locks
hey man can i just tell you about how
funny that joke was the one that
just felt so good to listen to poor
louis now free louie man
um but i didn't like the way he did the
dane [ __ ] i didn't like the way he
handled that
sarah i didn't like dan from jump before
he was i was like i just don't get it
yeah maybe i wasn't white so i was like
i just don't go with the big [ __ ]
deal
right do you even remember the joke i
don't remember the joke
no i don't isn't that funny we remember
the allegation we don't remember the
joke
yeah that's what's tough but i mean if
you watch carlos mencia
and the joker thief blaine plain thief
even beyond the fence-building joke that
i think wasn't that's a lot of people
will come up with that joke and a lot of
other comments have done it but
blai and thief uh yeah i will say this
about dane
um i mean as far as i was concerned he
put out a lot of comedy yeah and i
didn't hear that
any allegations besides louie no right
i think there was very minimal i think
dane was a weird guy
probably unlikable yeah but i don't know
if he was stealing
yeah you know and the jokes weren't and
this is not to like knock dane but like
the jokes weren't so like sophisticated
that like you would have to he didn't
need to steal because he doesn't rely on
his material
exactly such a performer that he could
go deliver
anyway um okay so i want to talk about
snl
yeah so snl comes out everybody uh
is [ __ ] on this week's episode of
snl and all these comics are [ __ ] on
this week's episode of snl
and they're really they're coming hard
on us another i mean they're saying like
the writing is trash like we have
friends that all work at snl that
i know for a fact are hilarious i think
sam jay is legit
maybe female but he's so so funny
michael che hilarious chris redd
hilarious
colin jones hilarious pete davidson when
he was doing stand up i'm not sure he's
doing any more but he was very very he's
a star dog
very very funny we're just talking about
standing yeah
[Laughter]
so um the question is always how do you
have such funny people and then create a
show that for whatever reason people
seem to see to say it's not that funny i
don't watch it again
but al you saw this week yeah and i
thought it was completely trash
really i didn't laugh at all all the
sketch is bad all the sketches were bad
i was really disappointed in chris rock
chris rock bomb yeah cause that's why i
watch it so chris rock he did his
opening monologue
he tried for a joke or two in the
beginning and then the rest was just
like
thoughtful [ __ ] yeah thoughtful [ __ ]
about state of the country it
it wasn't even that it wasn't even
provoking like at least when chappelle
did it it was like chris rocket has no
idea
but you don't have to compare them
that's the tricky thing and i understand
what you're doing but like and we're
going to do it naturally like we're
always going to compare lebron to jordan
because there's no one else to compare
him to
and i think that is like the trouble of
being chris rock in an era of chappelle
is no matter what you do
you only compared to the goat yeah but i
mean if you try to open up
saturday night live without stand up
like
only other person i knew who did that
was chappelle and even then i'm just
like
what are we doing here like i understand
you're trying to make a statement but
like this is saturday live it is a
comedy show due to comedy
no one is better in the world at doing
comedy on serious topics than chris rock
or dave chappelle for that matter
like they that's their gift they could
take the most serious harsh
concept and then find some little gem of
funny in it yeah
and i guess you're saying it's a
disappointment that you didn't get
chappelle will also reward you where
he builds up the tension for so long and
then something hits and then it just
gets you because you're
right you've got the tension building up
so make sense that makes rock isn't
stylistically like that yeah he's going
to be more traditional
and then even with the skits i was
expecting him to you know since he
started on
snl yeah i thought he would just find
that funny again and like it was the
whole time it looked like he was just
reading off the
uh you know teleprompter and he's never
seen those words before
yeah yeah i get it's a bummer to me man
because
and this is why i love the fact that
like we have the ability to put our own
stand up out like i love this sam put
her special hours on netflix i think
it's called 3 a.m or something like that
yeah
and uh you go check it out but it's like
che you can see his stand up
funny he's red i'm sure he has stuff out
but like the beauty of you putting your
stand up out
is you get to show how funny you are
when it's all on you yeah right before
you putting your own stand up out clips
whatever it is
your own special doesn't matter you were
as funny as the show you worked for
you said i'm saying so if you worked on
snl and that's the only time they could
see you in sketches people are like
oh yeah i guess he's kind of funny i
mean i see his sketches or i see weekend
update and i guess he's okay
but then when you see chase stand up
stand up you're like oh this is a
hilarious dude
and then nbc creates a filter
that doesn't allow certain jokes in and
those jokes may be
the ones that we find funniest and i'm
wondering when
snl is going to or nbc
whatever it is is going to learn that
the attitude towards comedy has changed
and they're going to need to change the
restrictions that they have
to meet that attitude because it seems
like i mean i
i have yet to see someone who's like yo
man snl is [ __ ] hysterical i loved it
it was the most amazing thing ever
and when you're not getting any of that
there's a problem
especially when you have people that we
all know are talented
it'd be one thing if there was no
talented writers creating
shitty comedy that you expect but when
you have talented writers that when left
to their own devices
have really successful [ __ ] yep and when
they're all together and they're on this
one platform and everybody's like yo
this is doo-doo
that's the platform bro yeah and maybe
it's up to lauren you know what it's
like maybe lauren is maybe lauren lost
it bro
you know what it's like maybe he got too
old man maybe lauren michaels who's the
guy who runs snl
maybe it's time to pass it off